in this segment we will go very fast
through a few definitions and facts that
remain true in the continuous case
everything is completely analogous to
the discrete case and there are
absolutely no surprises here so for
example we have defined joint pmfs for
the case of more than two discrete
random variables and we have a bunch of
facts about them in a similar manner we
can define joint PDFs for more than two
random variables and if you have
understood the material so far you can
guess how such a joint PDF will be used
for example you can calculate the
probability of a three dimensional set
by integrating the joint PDF over that
three dimensional set and there are
analogs of all the other formulas that
we have here where we follow the usual
recipe sums become integrals and pmfs
are replaced by PDFs finally when you
deal with a random variable which is
defined as a function of jointly
continuous random variables we can use
an expected value rule that takes the
same form as in the discrete case and
using the expected value rule we can
establish once more the usual linearity
properties of expectations so absolutely
no surprises here the derivations are
either completely straightforward or
they follow exactly the same line of
argument as in the discrete case with
just minor changes in notation